I worked with you years and years ago on
S La as I said 1990 uh it was 1990 and
uh you have not aged at all and it's
spooky it's like you're I'm aging on the
inside
Conan really oh 103 in my
heart so bitter oh my God yo it's
absolutely I don't know what you're
doing I don't know if you're drinking
the the blood of the undead I don't know
what you clearly do know what I'm doing
I do know what you're doing you who are
you kidding yeah it's is incredible what
are you doing are you leaving in a
living a completely stress-free life I
take I take very good care of myself um
you know I I I don't drink I I work out
a lot I you know I I've I've learned
some tricks over the years give me a
trick because I am rotting like old
fruit yeah I'm like a pumpkin uh that
you like left on a shelf forgot about it
and now like the juice is just coming
out the
bottom it's just disgusting you know
Conan for you and I and I say this with
with with love yeah um whenever someone
says that it's pretty mean right I'm
going to get ready I think you're you're
looking at it an entire face
removal wait wait I've never heard of
that I've heard of face lifts and tug
who removes the face that's the harshest
thing I've ever heard that's what you
think
old okay I'm going to look into that the
old face removal that'll be great no one
notice a skull out here r
I um you have called yourself an
adrenaline junkie yeah well because I
don't cuz I like I said I don't drink so
I or do any of the crazy stuff I used to
do when I was wild and young and so I've
got to find a way to let you know the
wild man out so it's you know skiing and
surfing and doing all you know adrenal
and stuff do you push the envelope with
that stuff like well I ski but I don't
go crazy I mean I like to ski but I
don't would you really take it you try
and go like 50 miles an hour down the
slopes I I used to and now I'm trying to
ski more like a 50-year-old breadwinner
yeah you know that's sort of the level
I'm aspiring to cuz if I go down the
whole train stops uh I like to ski and
when I go off to ski uh people on the
staff have actually said to me you're a
paycheck right exactly you can't get
hurt but I've tried other stuff I've
tried boring stuff that you're supposed
to do you know I've tried I tried Golf
and I gave golf up because I killed the
Iowa State Bird In Flight in a golf
tournament did you really what tell what
did you do tell me that story I well I I
went to a a you know PGA proam celebrity
thing in in the state capital of Iowa
and I had a really I thought nice Sand
Wedge just was do was leaking ever so
slightly maybe the left but looking
good boink in the air dead into the Trap
and this isn't like what is the state
what is the state bird well that's the
thing it's not like Randy Johnson the
pitcher who killed a seagull with a
throne that's a seagull it's a
finch the ball the the the bird is
literally a a finch it's like this the
golf Ball's like that
so it was the the the sponsors of this
tournament were uh an insurance company
so their actuaries did the math and
turns out the odds of me going to Iowa
and killing the state bird with a golf
ball shot in flight are one in
million that just sounds impossible
unless the bird was
suicidal and a hole in one is one in
500,000 right so this is unbelievable
that you did this unbelievable but I
figured you know I'm I'm I'm quitting
after yeah while you're head that's
fantastic right yeah real a real birdie
yeah yeah
exactly were people you know people get
mad about that kind of thing oh the Pea
people were
Furious they they they actually were I
was saying they clearly know nothing
about golf so I was like okay I let me
see if I get this straight if I went out
it would take me what is it 747 million
shots to kill a live bird in Flight I
couldn't have done it on purpose but
they uh they were were they were not
happy made it would have been cool if
you acted like you did it on purpose you
know that's what I would have done I
would have hit the bird and then run up
to it and been like psych right in your
face his head off and shoot the feathers
out you know yeah at least eating it
just to make not in vain yeah right Died
For A Cause next time I will uh we have
to take a quick break much more with Rob
low in just a second stick around